-Our next comedian
is a wonderful director
who's kicking off
his latest tour,
Please Stop the Ride
in Boston,
Seattle and Walla Walla,
Washington.
And his special,
"The Old Man and the Pool,"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-There was this sign growing
up that said "please shower
before entering the the pool."
And I feel like that was written
for one guy,
you know what I mean?
Like, I think the first draft
of that one said "Greg."
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Mike Birbiglia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-I'm good.
-Wonderful to be here.
-Great to see you.
-I'm very excited about
the tour.
One of the first stops
is Walla Walla, Washington,
which has great
historical significance to you.
-I have a personal story
that occurred
in Walla Walla, Washington,
almost 20 years ago,
which is -- people are going to
think I'm making this up.
But I jumped through a second
story window sleepwalking.
-Yeah.
-Of a -- true story --
of a La Quinta Inn.
[ Laughter ]
So this is sort of a --
-They have that problem
a lot at La Quinta.
-So this is sort of an ad.
[ Laughs ]
It's a true story.
Some people correct me.
They go, "No, no, no."
When I say La "Qwinta,"
they go, "No, it's La 'Kinta.'"
I'm like, you can't
force me to speak Spanish.
I didn't press
two or whatever,
but, uh, so no,
20 years ago,
I jumped through
a La Quinta Inn window.
-Which was then made famous.
You did a special, a movie,
"Sleepwalk with Me,"
which is wonderful.
-And then yeah, and so I --
I'm going back to Walla Walla.
I haven't been there.
So I was like,
I'm going to...
I've researched theaters,
and there's this beautiful place
called the Power House Theatre,
and I'm doing a couple shows
and I'm going to bring
a camera and film myself,
like, going back
to the motel room.
I found out -- true story --
No.
And so I called to rent
the room.
Because we actually put up
a plaque next to the room.
-This is also a true story.
-This is true.
-So you just sent this to
the La Quinta Inn.
-Yeah.
So it says "In this room,
on January 26, 2005,
comedian Mike Birbiglia
sleepwalked out the window.
That story became the basis
for the book
and feature film
'Sleepwalk with Me.'
Seriously. Google it."
[ Laughter ]
And that's real.
And sometimes people go,
fans of mine will make
the trip to Walla Walla
and they'll stay in the room,
which is like
the weirdest attraction ever.
-I can't believe they put it up.
It's really -- I mean,
I think that's a real honor
that they were like,
I mean, I guess they probably
almost never get a plaque sent.
-Well, that's the thing.
You can make plaques,
you can make trophies.
I mean, my new
special "Old Man and the Pool"
is up for a Critics' Choice
award in January.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm not going to win.
I'm not going to win.
But I'm going to make
myself a plaque afterwards.
-Why not? Right?
[ Laughter ]
Why not?
-No one's going to contest that.
-It's not like the plaque
makers are like, "But did you?"
-"But did you?
We're going to have
to see some paperwork."
-"There's some integrity
in the plaque industry."
-No. And so I'm going back
and I -- So, I called
the La Quinta Inn
and I said, "Hey,
I'd like to rent this room"
and then it's not
a La Quinta Inn anymore.
They're like,
"That's not this motel,
that's another motel."
They said that's a -- I think
that's a Comfort Inn now.
-Okay.
-So I call the Comfort Inn.
I go, "Hey, I jumped through
the second story window."
[ Laughter ]
I go, "I believe
there's a plaque on the wall."
They go, "No, no, that's
actually the Quality Inn."
-Wow.
-I call the Quality Inn.
[ Laughter ]
True story.
I call the Quality Inn.
[ Laughter ]
I go, "I'm Mike Birbiglia.
I believe there's a plaque
on the wall of me."
They say, "Oh, yes,
there it is."
I go, "I'd like
to rent that room."
And the guy goes,
"Could you hold?
I'm going to talk
to my manager for a second."
True story.
And I'm like, "Oh, okay.
'I'm going to talk
to the manager.'
They're going to roll out
the red carpet."
The way we all know
the Quality Inn does.
[ Laughter ]
-Step one, I think they're
going to have to go
buy a red carpet.
[ Laughter ]
-Step two, the carpet
is already red from the blood.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're about to
stay there, Mike!
-So the --
So the manager comes,
the man, he goes,
"I got to talk to my manager."
I'm thinking it's going
to be a big deal.
Like, they're going to make
something -- Comes back.
He goes, "Great news.
We're going to give you 10% off
the room."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That's quality.
-So the lesson here,
if you want 10% off your room
at Quality Inn,
you need to either
join Quality Inn Rewards
or jump through
their second story window.
[ Applause ]
And then you get the red carpet.
-Then you get the red carpet.
-God knows how it became red.
-I just like at some point
I feel like all the Walla Walla
hotels were calling around
being like,
"Just FYI, there's a weird guy."
-I know.
-"He's just calling up
saying he sent a plaque."
-Such a bizarre -- I mean,
it truly is like
one of the more bizarre things
you could imagine occurring.
-I know,
but it's all by your hand.
Like, you're talking about it
like they were weird.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-Like you're the guy who, one,
walked out a window,
two, sent a plaque,
and then, three, were
calling around like you
were the king of hotels.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you know
what's great about it, too,
is I told the story recently.
And I'm going to
tell it in Walla Walla.
But I always tell the story.
I go, "I jumped
through the window,
I'm bleeding, you know,
I'm in my underwear."
I'm like, "I need to walk
to the front desk
and explain what happened."
True. I walked up
to the front desk and I go --
Fortunately, it wasn't
the smartest person
I've ever encountered,
and I feel like he might have
felt that way about me as well.
-Sure, sure. Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I'm going back.
I'm going to --
I'm actually going to try to
find the desk clerk.
He messaged me on Instagram
at one point.
I'm going to try
to find the doctor
who puts stitches in my legs,
who also, like, reached out.
Everybody -- It's a community.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I bet they all remember it.
-Every 20 years.
No, it was the first time
we're all getting the team
back together.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to re-enact it.
-Yeah.
-You know.
-Speaking of doctors,
"Old Man and the Pool,"
which is wonderful.
-Yeah. Thanks so much.
-I saw it live,
and now it's on Netflix.
-You brought your mom.
-I did, I brought my mom
and my brother.
We loved it.
You're the -- You talk about
a doctor basically says
you should start swimming
and that's the story.
But your actual doctor
came and saw the show.
-First of all, my doctor came.
First of all, this morning --
This is how unintimidating
I am as a celebrity.
No one ever is intimidated
to be like,
"We shouldn't go up
and say hi to him.
It might go badly." Literally
someone today goes,
"Hey, I haven't seen you
at the YMCA pool lately."
I'm like, "I don't know you.
How are you this --
How are you -- I'm just..."
-Yeah.
-I think people view me
like a wild animal.
They're like,
"It's more afraid of you
than you are of it."
[ Laughter ]
Like, you know,
the walrus is around.
You can talk to him.
You know what I mean?
No, but, yeah,
my doctor came, which was great.
I have a great doctor,
and I'm really lucky.
But she did, like,
after she saw the show,
I talked about how I had bladder
cancer, type two diabetes.
I sleepwalked through
a second story window.
After she saw the show,
she was, I think, much more
concerned during our visits
because I think when you see it
in a one-hour format,
it's like
I'm performing my chart.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
Nobody usually gets a Netflix
special about their maladies.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Right. When you see it
on a clipboard as a doctor,
you're like,
"I can deal with all this."
And then you see it
on a Netflix special,
you're like, "I think
this guy's a lost cause."
[ Laughter ]
-And I --
And I think I had
the ultimate call
out of my doctor's offices,
which is I stepped on the scale
when I went
to my doctor recently,
and it's still the old-fashioned
abacus thing,
like, you're not 1,000 pounds,
you're not 0 pounds,
you're not 970 pounds,
you're not 21 pounds,
you're not 650 pounds,
you're not 111 pounds.
I'm like, "What time is it?"
You know, she's like,
"It's not 2:00, it's not 6:00,
it's not 2:50, it's not 4:45."
No, I don't know why they still
have those, but that's...
-It's the best.
-Yeah.
-I wanted to ask real quick
because I feel like
we are both blessed
with very honest wives.
I think your wife, Jen,
you've been married 15 years.
I know she's very good
with feedback.
Is that accurate?
-She's amazing.
-And, you know, I think
that sometimes
it's mostly upside
to have an honest wife.
But like, sometimes,
you know...
-I think it's all dynamics,
right?
Like, so in every --
We've been married 15 years.
I think one of the upsides
of marriage is communication.
So like you just have to --
there's so little
you have to say words-wise
to convey an idea.
Like, our friend Mulaney
a few years ago was like,
"Hey, I'm going skydiving
for my birthday.
Do you want to come?"
And I was like,
"That sounds amazing.
I'd never thought of doing
that in my life."
And I went back to Jen and I
relayed this conversation to her
and she said,
"You're going to do that?"
And that's when I realized
I wasn't going to do that.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "No way.
Why would I want
to do an activity
that seems so dangerous,
yet so fun?"
Because ultimately,
I'm more afraid
of my wife's judgment of me
than I am of jumping out
of an airplane at 30,000 feet
because both activities
are dangerous.
But at the end of one of them,
you get to die.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very excited about this.
You grew up in Massachusetts.
You're doing 10 shows.
-At the Wilbur.
One of the great stand-up
theaters in America.
10 shows in a row in Boston.
That must just be so exciting.
-10 shows in Boston,
my hometown.
Going to do --
We're calling it
Christmas Parmesan.
Because in my family,
we didn't do a very religious
Christmas.
If anything, the theme
was just chicken Parmesan.
-Well, that's very exciting
for the people of Boston
that you're going to be there,
You guys, that's Mike Birbiglia.
"The Old Man and the Pool"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."